[Music]
let's go to uh matthew in
jackson mississippi what's up matthew
how are we doing man
i'm doing well how are you doing john
i'm doing good so what's up brother how
can i help
all right so uh me and my wife got
married in the
middle of 2020 um i'm 24 and she's 23.
uh and through since then we've
gone through a bunch of different trials
already but the most recently my mom
passed away from covid oh
man in february um she was 54
you know had no prior health issues um
she's the she's the outlier
and all the statistics but uh hey man
hey man i'm sorry that happened i hate
that for you
we're uh it's it's
it was set in stone before we were we
were here yeah
oh man anyway so my wife is a
surgical trauma icu nurse boy okay
and so she sees stuff like that every
day all day um
and so my question is is how do we go
about
grieving this together you know because
i
my my career is completely different
with her she's
almost immune not immune to seeing
things like that but she grieves
a lot differently than i do and um
anyways we're just
trying to trying to figure out how to
manage that
well man i love your question and the
fact that you're asking this question at
23 24
tells me you're way way way ahead of the
game
you're you're a decade and a half ahead
of where i was man or a decade of where
i was
when i figured this stuff out man so
good for you um
a couple of things one everybody grieves
differently
and the beauty of a relationship is
holding space
for the person that you care about and
love to grieve differently than you
and continually leaning in especially
where it's uncomfortable
when you're saying can we for god's sake
just move on
this is not still a thing or you have to
shower right those
some of those frustrating moments with
somebody else
saying how how are you already over this
like i can't breathe
or every time i see a picture of my mom
my heart stops again right
and so it's just holding space which
means you have to have
some really open and vulnerable
conversations
and those can be tough especially for
newlyweds because that's something that
you practice
along the way right and something you
guys got thrown into the deep end of the
pool
uh how did you grieve your mom's death
man um
lately yeah we've started too
i've i've got a really good group of a
small group that meets once a week and
um
and so that's been one of our uh one of
my outlets of grieving
was just because i can you know it's a
group of guys we meet and
uh i can be vulnerable with and talk
about
you know how i truly am feeling um and
so that's been
one of my biggest ways um and
we we hadn't really grieved it
completely yet
yeah it's still still pretty raw yeah
um is your dad still in the picture
he is um it's been real tough on him
and it's
part of me feels like i've not been able
to grieve because of his
grieving yeah um
so they were go ahead yeah go ahead
and they were they were uh married for
they've been together about 40 years or
so they were since they were in middle
school in high school
oh it's been uh it's been real hard on
the whole family
yeah so he's losing
yeah he lost two-thirds of himself right
yes sir yeah man like that's that's
yeah that's when you learn like you lose
the ability to breathe
and the ability to think and the ability
to make any sort of decision because
you've
those things have been intertwined in
another person you wouldn't trade it for
the world right
but man that's an abrupt end then it's
heartbreaking and it's hard to even wrap
your head around it man
so in the same way that your wife is
gonna have to create space for you
that's gonna look different from one
another
you and your dad are gonna grieve
differently too and
where that can get hard is you're going
to feel like i'm not grieving like he is
or am i grieving enough or he's
overdoing it or he's underdoing it and
one of the ways we distract ourselves
from our own pain is by
looking out into the world and
trying to make judgments on it right
trying to say you're not doing enough
you're doing too much
i can't believe you said that leave me
alone all of those are defense
mechanisms for the
big hole that's sitting right in the
middle of our chest which is
mom was taken way way way too young
right
she never got to hold her grandkids she
never got filled in the blank man
like we had all these plans and
um did we all able to have a funeral
we were good so that
that really put good closure to it but
uh not closure
it was a it was a way to say i love you
through a ceremony
right closure's going to take years
and if you if you leave a funeral
thinking
this should be done now then you end up
attaching
shame and frustration and it leaks out
all over the place
in being short with people and being
angry and firing off emails and not
sleep in all those other ways
because your body's still trying to
process this grief that we've got like
we've got a hey it should be over now
you get three days off of work and get
your butt back in the office right so
um what i would challenge you with is to
find the things that help you grieve and
honor your mom
whatever that looks like if that's
writing mom a letter if that's
opening up an email account that only
you and your wife have access to and you
write your mom an email once a week
just to say you miss her just to tell
her something funny happened i don't
know what your relationship with her was
like before this
but there's something about the
continuity there
the the continue letting continually
letting some of the stuff out
in a planned way it'll find its way out
and then back to your wife for folks who
work in trauma
you have to have a separate process for
professional
secondary trauma and your own personal
real trauma
i've seen this over and over and i've
done it myself
which is man if you live and work in the
trauma of other people for a living
it's real easy to say hey that's just a
body or
yep people die let's go ahead and set
this up
i can have some really direct frank
conversations with my friends
about people who passed away in their
world or sickness or mental health
issues
i've got to really hold space to own my
own pain
otherwise i'll blow over it and it will
build up and build up and build up and
it will bury me
and so it may be that your wife has just
rolled mom up in this season
as a yet another trauma as one is what i
do it's how i process it and what i'll
tell you is man she's going to be burned
out on that job within a few years and
be really struggling with purpose and
value in what i do next
yeah and i would recognize you may not
have known how long does she know your
mom two years three years five years
about three years okay so it's a big
deal not
near what it is for you and what she's
got to learn to hold space for
is that you're grieving hard and the guy
she loves is struggling
right yeah and she does a really good
job about
making sure i'm doing okay and just
asking you know how
i was emotionally that day so she does a
great job doing that
good and uh for for us it's hard because
she'll come home and you know she's a
verbal
processor or she'll start talking about
her day and
um yeah no
nope yeah so listen people who work in
trauma also bury their spouses with
i when i whenever i'm training you know
medical students or counseling students
or doing continuing ed for those groups
i'll always say don't ever use your
spouse as a garbage bin
they didn't sign up for that so if you
need somebody to talk to you about what
you've seen
you should have a group at work or
nurses whatever you process that kind of
stuff with
i've got two or three people in my life
that i could process
the actual things i saw
right i could talk to it with
dr long i could talk to it with sarah
with
andy i could talk to a couple of my
teammates and that was about it
i remember a couple of times at a like
hanging out with my
closest buddies and say guys guess what
i saw last night and i would tell them
about some extraordinary
scene i and they
look like appropriately so right
like i had melted them and so i learned
hey man they didn't ask for this
that's not a cool thing to dump that on
them and so i'm never gonna do that
again
so your wife has to learn that and what
i would tell her is
that in a loving kind respectful way
at this season i can't hear about all of
the
wild things you see at work i need you
to find some friends that can hear the
trauma parts
i would love to hear about your day i
want to hear about how you're doing how
the offices go i won't hear about those
things
but i can't hear about people passing
away i can't hear about the
failed catheters and the failed you know
and the
all the all the trauma that goes on
inside her role
right and i would do that in a loving
kind way so that she can
wrap her head around it and um you still
love her i still
we're still all still in this together
but at this season in the season i can't
hear that
it may be that someday you love hearing
about that stuff probably not
me and my dad could talk about that
stuff but me and my mom sure did not
my dad grew up seeing it my mom didn't i
don't talk about that stuff with my
brother with my sister
so there's just very few people we can
talk about that
but i'd recommend writing your mom a
letter man until you miss her and that
you love her
let your wife know you're doing this and
then for the next four or five or six
months
once a month when y'all do your budget
for the month
when you all go over your calendar for
the month or for the week just check in
how are you doing with mom's passing i'm
still struggling
or i'm getting better things are tough
or i'm calling dad today just to check
in on him
and just so you know man if you continue
to talk about this continue to be open
continue to have a respectful
and dignified dialogue together
that inability to breathe you'll slowly
find yourself taking deeper breaths
you're always going to miss your mom
always but it won't always hurt so bad
and at some point you'll make meaning
out of this whether it's sitting with
guys who have
experienced this you know
being a vaccine advocate whatever who
knows right
but you'll begin to make meaning of this
and then that story will be yours to
tell
so thanks so much for the call brother
um so sorry to hear about your mom so
sorry to hear about that